- Hey, this is Nicky Jam.
Listen to Monday to Monday.
You're gonna love it.
Nicky Jam.
- [Gary] I only like the process.
- [Nicky Jam] It's the best thing.
- It's the only thing for me.
Like, I'm addicted to,
there's nothing else I like.
I don't like stuff.
I don't want stuff.
I just want the legacy of the process.
You know what I mean?
- I know what you mean.
- And that's why yours is so good,
compared to other things.
Like, when it's just like this...
- You don't miss the process?
- I'm only about the process.
I always put myself in the process.
That's why I jump from
different businesses.
Like, once I won wine, I bounced,
'cause I was like, "What am I gonna do,
just milk it for the riches?"
That's what most people do.
- That's the problem.
- They only wanna do the
sh-- to get to the stuff.
They're willing to put in the work
for the Lamborghini, or
the girls, or the chains,
but once they get it, they're out.
That's why so many people
lose once they win.
- And he's tight with Russia.
- I know, I know.
- That's our guy.
- That's my guy.
I love that dude.
- [Nicky Jam] Yeah, that's my boy.
- He's a good guy.
Like, good people.
- [Nicky Jam] He is.
Very smart too, very sharp.
He's got good instincts.
- He is sharp.
He's got great instincts.
That's a really good way to put it.
What's really interesting, though,
is it's your time now, right?
Like, you were born at the right time.
Like, you guys are taking over the world.
Like, the whole, like Latin-
the Latin-vasion of America
is forever over.
It's not going backwards.
It's only, like, this
is just the beginning.
People don't get it.
Like, the demographics, it's just math.
It's over.
It's really cool, it's really cool.
- Awesome.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and one thing we were,
I introduced Sid to some of your team,
but you didn't get a chance to meet.
So this is Sid, right here.
He does international strategy for Gary.
One of the coolest things to me
was when you were talking
about how you went
to Colombia and you were, like,
going hard after YouTube, to, like,
get your numbers up, and
you were really, like,
got all your followers and everything up.
- See, the thing is,
when I went to Colombia
I saw there were 65,000,000 people
and my career was in a downfall,
so I said, "If I can make
this country love me,
and I could be the number one national,
if I could make a national hit,
number one national hit in this country,
I'll get 65,000,000 people to back me up,
and if I get 65,000,000 people to love me,
other people from other countries,
like why this guy has so many views?"
- Yo, I gotta be straight up with you.
Straight up, real quick.
It's my favorite thing about you.
You understand that that's a talent
that will never go away from you, right?
Because, whether it's
Colombia, or Snapchat,
or E-Sports, or this famous person,
it's just the math of attention.
To have the understanding to get up, go,
execute like that...
Oof.
- [Nicky Jam] Yeah, I mean...
- That never will go away from you.
- That's, that's, that's...
- It's the same game.
It's all I ever do.
It's just attention.
- Exactly, exactly.
And that's the thing.
I had to study the country and
make the country love me, not bec-
Me not being from that country
and not being active in
the music in the moment,
'cause Colombia was
listening to reggaeton music,
but they wasn't into the
guys that were active
in the moment.
So I had to go there and make,
make them fall in love with me,
but it was easy 'cause they were like,
"Yo, this guy's living in our country.
He loves us."
You know?
Saying, "Why isn't he, why
isn't he living in the States?
Why isn't he living in Puerto Rico?
And he's coming over here."
and I started doing
videos, 15 second videos,
and I'm like, "Yo, I'm over here
in the streets of Medellin, walking,
and don, don, don, don,
I'm doing this, and I'm,
I just bought my new, uh, Mazda 6."
(laughing)
And, normally, rappers
brag about Bentleys,
and I'm happy 'cause I have a car again.
So, so they fell in love with my story
and it worked exactly how I wanted it to.
I didn't have one number one hit,
I had six number one hits in Colombia,
national hits, and my
views were incredible,
and I started jumping from
Colombia to the world.
- You know it's funny.
I think about hunting and farming.
Now the key for you to have, like,
a 50, 100 year career,
like, at this new level,
'cause you've had a career,
you need to be very thoughtful
of forever giving love to that country.
Like, everything you guys, right?
- Always.
- Like, the number one
thing for you to be able
to win in Asia, on
Mars, on a new platform,
you need to be real thoughtful
about how you continue to
give love there forever.
- [Nicky Jam] Yeah.
- You have to have,
you know what you should do?
You should, uh, you should make the day
you put your first video up in Colombia
like a holiday within
your world, in your mind,
and with your fan, and, like, literally
always do something special on that day.
You should go back, look at the first day
you posted something
on YouTube in Colombia,
if that's what you give credit for it
when you first started,
look at that date, and you
should throw a free concert
every year on that date for life.
- That's awesome.
That's really awesome.
- Another thing is,
like what he was saying
about how humble he was
in Colombia, and, like,
what Gary loves is the
lyrics and the story.
And I know that you were saying,
in Puerto Rico is was more about beats,
and this and that...
- I don't understand,
like, beats and producers
that well, I really don't.
Like, I get it,
like, if a, like, if the
music, like, I get it,
but I know that I'm not
thoughtful about that.
But the story, that's...
- That's everything.
- For me, it's everything.
- [Nicky Jam] That's
everything, that's everything.
- Like, for me, that's for me.
Like, I think everybody
has their own thing.
For me, and then the story of the person,
that's why, usually, I
love people's first albums,
because that's their origin story,
that's their first issue
of the comic book, right?
That's when they're telling people, like,
"This is what happened and
this is what happened."
I think it takes a lot
for somebody to have that
second or third, like, it's the person
that knows how to story tell
of what they're going through,
because the first one, that's your truth.
It's kinda how my
Keynotes work on YouTube,
my business talks.
Like, it used to be easy 'cause I'd just
tell you I was born in Russia and lived
in a studio apartment with
this many family members,
this is, like, how I grew up.
Like, you know?
But then, then it got harder
because that was established
and now you gotta come
back with some hits.
- Yeah, he started Keynotes the same way
you started your album,
like, telling the story,
like, you know, like, telling
everything is like how...
- So now what?
'Cause it's white hot right now.
You guys must all be like,
"Okay, we need to be, like..."
- Well, you know, my
mentality is, first of all,
in my music and the general
music of reggaetones,
it was kinda hard to
work and do big things,
'cause, you know, they
saw us as street singers,
you know what I'm saying?
So normally, like,
you'll see a Ricky Martin
or a Luis Fonsi, or a Enya, it will be
easier for them to, you
know, work with brands
and sponsorship and all stuff like that.
So I'm breaking those boundaries,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm pushing it, and I'm being the first,
you know, I just work, I
just signed with Hublot,
I just signed with, uh, I'm
doing the Netflix thing,
I'm doing, uh, I got something big working
with Will Smith, I'm doing the movies,
I did the movie with Vin Diesel, I did,
I'm doing things for my
music and that I wanna be,
like, you could say, the
Jennifer Lopez of my music,
you know what I'm saying?
I want, 'cause I'm bilingual,
I can, I'm good acting, and
that's what I'm trying to do.
- That J. Lo money is interesting money.
- [Nicky Jam] It is.
(laughing)
- But you know what's amazing about her,
and amazing about, 'cause I've been
really digging into you
the last couple months?
Work.
- [Nicky Jam] Work.
- I just wish J. Lo, I
get so mad at culture.
When I hear J. Lo's name,
literally the first thing
I think of is a working gangster.
- [Nicky Jam] She is.
- She hustles.
She works.
And, like, when everybody
talks about her, like,
they talk about her being
a celebrity, or her a--,
or, like, whatever, and
I'm like, such disre-
Like, she's working.
Like, J. Lo's outworking
99.9999% of people.
Will Smith is working.
The reason you got something brewing
with Will Smith is Will Smith's smart.
He realized the game he was playing
for the last two decades was, time was up.
You can't make the same
movie 15 times in a row
and get paid $20,000,000.
- [Nicky Jam] Exactly.
- This is the game.
He looked around, it felt authentic,
you got plenty of attention in the game,
you're pumped 'cause he's an icon,
one plus one equals two, right?
- Exactly.
Exactly.
- Listen to me.
I'm telling you right
now, 'cause I can tell
that you know everything, so I don't have
that much to give, that
first day you made a piece
of content, throw that free concert.
Your only Kryptonite right now
is if you forget about Colombia.
- Oh, yeah, no, I would never do that.
- [Gary] I'm being dead serious though.
- I say it in the songs everywhere.
- You're so natural to grow.
You know, like, you're like me.
Like, your natural move is to grow.
You're gonna win Asia,
you're gonna do the same-
You know you're gonna run this same racket
over and over, right?
Like, you're gonna win China the same way.
You're gonna win some new
platform the same way.
This is over.
Now that you've tasted
it, like, it's over.
You're just gonna rinse and repeat,
and the only vulnerability
is if it feels manipulated.
- That is true.
- You know what's funny?
I wouldn't even have given you the advice-
You're like me, you're transparent.
There's a lot of people
who did what you did
that would never say, "I
decided to go to Colombia
for that reason, 65,000,000,
if I could make them love me,
it worked exactly," like,
you have to understand.
If you're on the other side in Colombia,
humans are cynical.
They're like, "Oh, you just came," got it?
So you need to go hard the other way.
- No, of course, I mean, you know,
Colombians come to the
States to, you know,
to look for their dream.
I went to Colombia to
get my dream. (laughs)
- [Gary] Just need to go back.
- They're looking for the American dream,
and I was looking for the
Colombian dream for the world,
you know what I'm saying?
- By the way, your model's right.
Sid, what do I keep saying about a country
in South America?
What's my new thing?
Where do I wanna be famous?
- [Sid] Brazil.
- [Gary] Nope.
- [Man] Peru.
- Peru.
- [Man] You wanna be famous.
- I wanna be famous everywhere, but, but,
the reason I keep saying
Peru, and I haven't even,
I have no idea how many people live there,
it's more, it's not a joke,
it's more of a religion,
which is, what you did is
one of the first examples
of, like, this works for everybody, man.
Like, this is the right model.
Like, if you're a creator
right now out there,
for music or videos, taking a step back,
especially if you're young
and you can live anywhere,
and if you're willing to live humbly,
taking a step back and
looking at different places
around the world, because
YouTube and Facebook
and these platforms work
everywhere, Saudi Arabia,
now, with Snapchat, and
with this new prince,
every day I wish I was, like, 24 and had
no responsibilities and no
family, I'd pick my ass up
and go to Saudi Arabia right
now and fucking kill it.
- [Nicky Jam] That's nice.
- That's what you did.
- I mean, that's what I felt when I went
to Colombia, exactly.
- You had even a bigger advantage,
because you already had an up and a down,
so you had a chip.
- [Nicky Jam] Exactly.
- Even better than being a young kid.
You had experience and a chip...
- I lost my ego.
No ego.
- Correct.
Once you triple down on humility,
and still have ego and hunger...
- [Nicky Jam] Exactly.
- As long as humility's
just .1% bigger than ego,
it's game over.
That's what Will has.
All that Will Smith
has just done is he let
his humility go a little
bit further than his ego.
That's why he was willing
to vlog and be on Myspace,
(laughs) Myspace, on Instagram...
(laughing)
I'm old, guys, I'm old.
- Come on, Tom.
(laughing)
- You know, the fact
that he had the humility
to go on there, most
A-list stars don't wanna go
to Instagram and YouTube because they have
to start at zero.
And then there's other
people out there, like you,
that have more followers.
They don't have the humility.
Humility's the key right
now for the next game.
- I have a question for you.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- Obviously you told me that, uh,
you get, you get bored and
you wanna do new things
and new things, but have
you, out of all the success
you already have, you
never, you never just, like,
"I'm tired"?
You never feel tired.
- Not yet.
And I say yet.
Right, like, who knows?
- Never bored?
Never bored.
- What takes the bored away
is doing something new and...
- I'm always doing, always doing.
Yeah, if I get, like,
I'm pretty disciplined,
which is why I can build
big companies, but,
and they'll tell you,
I'll just make up new s--t
that isn't big.
Like, I'm building a Twitch studio,
right outside my office.
That's me being bored, right?
Just need a little action, a little hint
of something new, but I
keep 89%, 92%, got it?
It's side dishes.
My steak and my chicken, it's proper,
but sometimes I need
some cauliflower, some,
you know, something new, right?
Side dishes keep me going.
Plus, I'm just grate-,
honestly, I'm grateful.
Like, to me, I'm just grateful,
which never gets me down
or negative or bored or,
just grateful.
I'm just hungry, you know?
- You love yourself.
- I love myself.
I love myself.
That's a really good way to put it.
And, for most people, that's
a difficult thing to say
'cause the world doesn't
accept that super well,
but that's the answer for
everybody in this room
and everybody behind that camera.
My biggest thing, if
you look at my content,
I'm trying to get people
to love themselves.
The way you love yourself is
you become 100% accountability
for your shortcomings, 'cause everybody
in here's done dumb s--t.
- Of course.
- Every one of us has got shortcomings.
So first you get there, but, yeah, man,
I do love myself because
my mom made me that way
and no voice has been able to penetrate me
to tell me the alternative.
- Incredible.
You know, I believe in that
a lot, about loving yourself.
I mean, and it was hard
for me 'cause I came from,
my mom, she left me when
I was eight years old.
She was a drug addict and a prostitute.
My dad was a drug addict himself.
And it's kinda hard for
you to love yourself
when you come from that situation.
- [Gary] It's very hard.
- But I was trying to blame the world
when I was in drugs and
I was in, all messed up,
and blame my parents, and
when I started to love myself,
everything changed for me.
- How'd you get there?
- I mean, I was tired of,
I was tired of looking
at myself and then
blaming people, and saying
my life was a piece of s--t, and nothing
was happening for me.
So one day I said, "Okay, first..."
I was fat.
I was, like, really fat.
I was weighing almost 300 pounds.
I was taking so much Percs
a day, and the Percs,
it's not like other drugs
that will make you not eat.
The Percs will make you
eat more than a lot.
So I was, like the worst
drug addict 'cause I was
a fat drug addict.
Normally you don't imagine...
- [Gary] You're a drug addict
and you're fat. (laughing)
- You know what I'm saying?
It's like, at least
take the weight off me,
you know what I'm saying?
So I was a fat drug addict
and I was tired of that
and I realized that when
I started losing weight,
the attitude of the people
when they started seeing me
was different.
It was a different vibe.
It was like, "Hey, Nicky!
Hey, what's good?
Hey, wanna go eat something?"
They didn't say that when I was fat
and all messed up in drugs.
They wanna go, they wanna take me out
'cause they thought I looked good.
So everything, so I said,
"Okay, this is the beginning."
- How did that even start?
Like what's the, who,
like, what did you see,
or what, like, I'm always
fascinated by that,
the tipping point.
- Okay, what did I see
for the weight thing?
I think, I think, well, first of all,
I was at a Denny's, actually, eating
and a fat girl came to me and say,
what happened to me?
And it pissed me off.
And I said, "Same sh-- happened to you.
You fat.
What do you mean?
I was eating and I got fat."
- You knew her.
- Nah, she knew me 'cause
I was in the music,
you know what I'm saying?
You gotta understand, I was so skinny
when I was famous in
Puerto Rico the first time,
so when I got fat I was deformed.
You could say, like, "This
guy is not the same guy."
So, obviously, it's okay for a fat girl
to tell me...
- She rolled up on you and
was like, "What happened?"
- "What happened?", you
know what I'm saying?
But it was like, you
know, and it felt bad.
(Gary laughs)
It felt kinda bad, you
know, and I was like,
and then I said to
myself, "What happened?",
you know what I'm saying?
And then I said, "Okay."
So I said, "I'm gonna start
with the weight thing,"
and I started eating,
like, the cleanest thing
in every menu.
- Honestly, like, it's funny, it doesn't,
you know, that was your story.
My big thing is like bald,
short dudes, and, like,
overweight people, like, you've
got to figure out how to,
like, not make anything else
the way you justify your hab-
Like, it's gotta be an inside game.
- [Nicky Jam] Exactly.
- Like, listen, being
healthy's just a good idea
to live longer, but it's crazy to me
being secure and being insecure,
it comes in every shape and size.
It's wild.
I'm just thinking about
some friends who are both
overweight, underweight,
rich, poor, tall, short,
athletic, not, like, you know.
And you go through that in life.
Like, I remember somewhere in high school
and then early college when I was like,
"Wait a minute.
Pretty people are insecure too?"
- Of course, those are, they're the most.
- And it just runs the gamut.
- [Nicky Jam] They're the most.
- I'm just desperate to get people
to stop judging themselves.
- That's what you see a lot,
you know what I'm saying?
And it's crazy.
And, I mean, musicians are the worst.
Like, you could see them have,
they could be number one right now
on the billboard and the
press, you know, and just...
- Honestly, with the whole team here,
is there anything I can help with?
Is there anything we can help with?
Like, from anybody's perspective?
Your perspective, or anybody on the team
that might have one?
- I mean, I mean, there's
a lot of things. (laughs)
- [Gary] Throw 'em, throw 'em, throw 'em.
Listen, my natural, like, just
so you know me a little bit,
my natural default is I love
to give first 'cause I don't,
I'm perfect for giving.
I don't expect s--t in return,
and I know it also works in the end.
And if it works two out
of, like he'll tell you.
Ten years we're in to this journey, now.
- Yeah.
And I was telling him a little background.
You know, he's in Miami, so there's that.
- Yeah, I'm there a lot.
- So, like, I mean...
- No, one thing really
important for me right now,
like I was saying, I was, I'm
trying to be, like, the first
for my genre of music to work with these
- [Gary] The first mogul.
- Work with these brands,
you know what I'm saying?
So, I mean, I've been
working with (company name)
already, like, in Latin America,
but I would love to be the
Latin face of (company name),
you know what I'm saying?
In the world.
- In the U.S.
- U.S., world.
And sometimes, you know,
it's kinda hard being
a reggaeton artist, you
know what I'm saying?
So, you know, if you guys can
help me with anything of that,
it would be awesome.
- An interesting thing, though,
is that your music is great,
and your music isn't, like, offensive.
- It's not, it's not, it's not at all.
But sometimes they go by the image.
- It's a (indistinct)
image thing in the past
since our branding team has
always been pitching him
since day one.
And it's the background.
It's because of, you know,
some of the (indistinct),
which is hilarious because
you see a lot of people
with more questionable
pasts, but that's only
been the reason...
- We know what it is.
We all know what it is.
Let's go a different route.
I think you're making a mistake.
Let me explain.
You're not, first of all, you're
making the least mistakes,
but, it's funny, in some places
you're going real new wave
and other places you're
looking at it traditional.
I don't think you should do (company name)
because (company name) is
not gonna do anything for you
except be a short-term check.
And I get it.
Like, I grew up with Michael Jackson,
and we all know where (company name) sits.
I get it.
Let me throw a different one at you.
I think you should be
thinking about getting equity
in a start-up beverage, like Dirty Lemon,
who's smart enough to know that
you're exactly what they need.
You get a point of the
company on the back end.
They market you properly,
not on dumb billboards,
cheesed out, vanilla-ed out, right?
And you win twice.
To me, you've pa-
You know what you and I have?
- 'Cause their mentality is
that, "We don't need you.
You're already a organic, uh...
- You know what's funny?
You know what's funny?
It's not even that they
think that they need you
or they don't need you.
They don't know how
valuable you are, right?
And then it's just like, what?
And more importantly,
I think we all have to
start debating how valuable they are.
- [Nicky Jam] Yeah, makes sense.
- Like, what's good about (company name)?
You get paid and you
get national exposure.
You can get national exposure now.
Your fucking YouTube videos are seen
by a hell of a lot more than every fucking
(company name) commercial that runs
this year globally, combined.
Let's just take a second.
I want everybody here to take a second
and listen to me real carefully.
Your video that you posted two weeks ago
is consumed more, consumed, not aired.
There's a lot of (company
name) commercials
being aired, nobody's watching them.
I just think you need to get yours,
your value worth.
I think you need to start thinking about,
like, how much leverage you have.
For you to be the next J. Lo within this,
you can't do the same
blueprint that J. Lo did.
- [Nicky Jam] I gotta go my route.
- You gotta play a 2018 to 2023 route.
You need to be worried
about kids that are playing
on Twitch, and getting your
music into their channels.
You need to be thinking
about start-up brands
that are going direct to consumer,
that are targeting the
Latin American consumer.
You need to be doing you.
You need to reverse it.
They need you.
And their check is getting
less and less interesting,
thank God. (knocks on table)
Right?
- [Nicky Jam] True that.
- Making a couple dollars.
And more importantly, the more you realize
how much or how little you actually need-
The reason I'm dangerous is I don't need
to make a lot of money
every year, which means
I'm putting the energy into the bank,
giving myself long-term leverage.
- So you got the number
of the lemon company
you were saying, so I can call them?
(laughing)
- I do, I do, but...
We'll be happy to help.
You need to look at all of it.
There may be a very authentic-
First of all, you start with authenticity.
Like, if you drink orange soda, like,
we need to look at Fanta's
U.S. strategy first.
You wanna talk about a brand that could
really get popping because of you?
And needs to?
Like, Fanta should team up with you and
three or four others, they
could be off to the races.
Like, Fanta is the most
interesting soda brand to me
because it's actually culturally relevant
outside the U.S., they
wanna do more business
in the U.S., but they
don't have the right faces.
So, I think you have the options.
I think you have the leverage down.
It's all so new, it happened so fast
this second time around, you have to be
thoughtful about it, but I'd go backwards.
I would literally, with the team, sit down
and think about everything
you actually like,
and just know that you could
actually jam with them,
because then it's gonna
be a better relationship
anyway, 'cause it's not
a check, it's authentic.
- [Nicky Jam] Exactly.
- And whether that's a
Kleenex, or a sneaker,
or what have you...
- [Nicky Jam] Anything.
- Anything.
And if it's neutral, like,
if you don't give a f--k,
then I would go to something new, not old.
Like, you better really, like, for me,
if I started from the beginning,
you need to love Hublot,
like, love it, love it.
If not, I'd take step back.
Listen, there's more ears
on your music right now
than Jay-Z's music when
he dropped that song.
It just, it's real,
it's hard to comprehend
'cause it all changed, and
so when you deploy humility
like you're deploying, it's sometimes hard
to wrap your head around.
- [Nicky Jam] That's true.
- But, like, you can build the next Hublot
with one mention.
Could.
You could.
Now, you can't do that for every category.
You gotta be thoughtful.
Sometimes it's good to take the check,
sometimes it's good to have the back end,
sometimes it's good to floss.
I get it, but you need
to be really thoughtful
about your brand strategy,
and it needs to be
forward thinking, not what has happened.
- [Nicky Jam] Yeah.
- And if you own a part
of a company like that
you'll be, like, looked at as
the business guy, you know?
You'll be like, "Wow, he's so smart."
Like, Nicky Jam, the business man,
like, taking part of this company,
blowing it up, that
jacket, whatever, like,
even that is valuable.
- This has been huge for me.
He's here?
This has been huge for me.
Like, right?
K-Swiss hadn't been hot for 20 years.
Ice-T's a long time ago.
(in unison) K-Swiss.
- I did a collaboration...
- These sneakers?
You did a collaboration with K-Swiss?
- That's his sneaker.
- [Gary] Yeah, this was
the first one, right?
And this was a limited
edition thing I just did.
- This is the date the book came out.
- [Nicky Jam] I love
K-Swiss, that's classic.
Always look good.
- And that's what you
need to be thinking about.
If I'm you, I think
you think you're having
your second act.
I think you're looking
at Hublot, and fucking,
whether it's Supreme, or fucking Pepsi,
as, like, the thing that's anointing you.
I'd reverse it.
I would think about your life over the,
your whole life and think
about what you f--k with,
or, if you're neutral, look what I did.
I was neutral, but I didn't wanna do Nike
and those other stuff.
I went to K-Swiss 'cause
I'm getting the juice
for bringing it back.
If you bring back Nautica,
you win.
- [Nicky Jam] That's true.
- Champion...
- Got it?
Well, that's already been back, right?
- Yeah, all that stuff, yeah.
- But if you were the
reason Champion came back,
your career would be
different for the rest
of your life.
Not just riding Supreme
or Off-White, got it?
You got too much juice right now.
I would, back to me, just
throwing out some ideas,
I'd go really look at
some brand in Colombia
and bring it to America.
If you build a brand here in America
around something in
Colombia that makes jobs
for everybody, now you're talking about,
now you're starting to get into...
- Kinda like (indistinct)
with the Chinese brand.
- 100%.
Or like Under Armour did
for the Baltimore area.
They haven't left, they
rejuvenated that area with jobs.
- The thing is about these brands
having respect for the Spanish music,
'cause, you know, for some reason,
I'm gonna give you an example,
and no disrespect, this is what I think.
I mean, you know, I was
trying to work something
with Adidas and uh...
- Two minutes.
- Okay.
- I was talking to my guy, not you.
(laughing)
- I gotta go fast.
And I'm good freestyling, but...
- Dude, I know what you're, my man,
let me save you time.
I know what's gonna
come out of your mouth.
Listen to me, you're much more valuable
than they understand because they're not
as hip to the streets as you think.
Adidas is a corporation.
- They will give first a deal to Pusha T
that has 1,000,000 followers than me
that have 22,000,000.
- Brother, we see it every day.
When I told K-Swiss who
we should f--k with,
the list they gave me
in hip hop, I laughed.
I'm like, "You're just thinking..."
Big companies look backwards.
- [Nicky Jam] Okay.
- You're asking people
who don't have a pulse.
- So it's not a language barrier.
- Definitely not, because
they've picked other people.
And honestly, to be very honest with you,
you already went through this path.
You stopped making excuses.
If I'm you, you know how
lucky corporate America is
that I'm not a rapper?
The song I would have put
out right now about Adidas...
(laughing)
F--k Adidas.
Adidas is hot right now
for another few minutes.
They have a moment.
F--k Adidas.
But the truth is always
the thing to sing on.
You know what I mean?
I think it's gang-, I mean...
The number one thing I would do is
f--k with the establishment.
Like, Adidas and Supreme
would be at the top
of my list of things I'd
go after, not f--k with.
- [Nicky Jam] Okay.
- Especially if I had a reason.
I wouldn't just do it.
But, like, if you have a reason,
and you could do some silly stuff.
Like, you don't have to be like.
Like, you could do it,
you could do it your way,
but I'd have something for three stripes.
I'd make some sort of, "F--k you,
I'll make my fourth stripe."
You know?
Like, you know what I mean?
Like, you see where I'm going?
- [Nicky Jam] Yeah, I know what you mean.
- Or do you, like, Colombia's three, yeah.
This is just being creative, like,
I would, I would be like,
"Three stripes didn't wanna
f--k with me, the only
three stripes I f--k with
are the colors of," then you list off
the colors of Colombia.
That's me, that just sums
up exactly what I would do.
If you listen to everything I talked about
for the last 30 minutes, that's...
- I'm recording everything.
(laughing)
- But, see where I'm going?
You do that, if you dis
Adidas for not f--king
with you heavy, and you
gave love to Colombia
all in one line, f--king explode.
And then, God forbid,
sales of Adidas declined
by 4% in Colombia after that dropped,
now you're showing your power.
- And you know the
Colombian-American people.
- Listen, you've been through this game.
Take every, you've taken a macro no,
you got a macro f--k you, and that's why
you rose like a phoenix,
take every micro no
you have right now and let that feed you.
You're looking for one last validation
that the top 50 are playing at.
That top 50 doesn't mean s--t.
It's over.
And I don't give f--k
about getting co-signed
by the top 100.
I'm the new top 100, it's
just a matter of time.
- And he's doing cool, organic s--t.
I know we gotta go, but he's doing a song
with Vin Diesel, and that's because
they're actually friends,
you know what I mean?
Like, like real s--t.
- Yeah, listen, I do my homework.
You've won the second
you drop giving a f--k
about this last 1%, right?
Pepsi, Adidas, those
celebrities, that network,
is the second you take that next step,
that dangerous step.
- [Nicky Jam] I'm going there.
Thank you so much.
You have a good day.
(hip hop music)